so
your powerful precise rigorous words
are uh stand in a
uh stark contrast i would say to my very
recent conversation with oliver stone
now i would love you to elaborate to
this agreement you have here
with his words and maybe words of people
like john
mearsheimer
the idea is that putin's hand in this
invasion of 2022 was forced
by the expansion of nato
the imperialist imperative
of the united states
and the the
nato forces
you disagree with this point
in terms of placing the blame
somehow on the invasion on
uh
forces larger than the particular two
nations involved but
more on the geopolitics of the world
that's driven by the most powerful
military nation in the world which is
the united
in new st
and a woman got raped
we know the perpetrator
they go to trial
and oliver stone gets up and says you
know what
the woman was wearing a short skirt
and there was no option but for the
rapist to rape her
the woman was wearing lipstick
or the woman was applying for nato
membership and just had to be raped
there's i mean
didn't want a raper
but was compelled because of what she
was doing and what she looked like and
and the clothes she was wearing and the
alliances that she was under
international law
signed by moscow all the treaties
that sovereign countries get to choose
whatever alliance they belong to
uh treaties that the u.n charter
signed by russia the soviet union the
1975 helsinki
agreement
signed by the soviet union the 1990
charter of paris for a new europe signed
by the soviet union the 1997 nato russia
founding act
signed by the russian government the
post-soviet russia all of those
documents signed by
either the soviet regime or the russian
regime which is the legally recognized
international
inheritor right successor of the soviet
state all of those agreements are still
in force and all of them say
that countries
are sovereign and can freely choose
their foreign policy and what alliances
they want to join
let's even go farther than that i mean
you don't have to go farther than that
but let's go farther than that lex
is an autocratic repressive regime that
invades its neighbors in the name of its
own security something new in russian
history did we not see this before
is this
does this not predate nato expansion
does this not predate the existence of
nato would oliver stone sit here in this
chair and say to you you know
they had to impose serfdom in the 17th
century
because nato expanded they had no choice
their hands were tied they were
compelled
to treat their own population like
slaves because you know
nato expanded i mean i could go on
through the examples of russian history
that predate the existence let alone the
expansion of nato
where you have
behavior
policies actions
very similar to what we see now from the
kremlin and and you can't explain those
by nato expansion can you
and so that argument doesn't wash for me
because i have a pattern here that
predates nato expansion
i have international agreements founding
documents signed by the kremlin over
many many decades
acknowledging the freedom of countries
to choose their alliances
and then i have this problem where when
you rape somebody
it's not because they're wearing a short
skirt
it's because you
have raped them
you've committed a criminal act lex
that's a i think there's a lot of people
listening to this
that will agree to the emotion the power
and the spirit of this metaphor i was
struggling to think
how to dance within this metaphor
because it feels like it wasn't
precisely the right one but i think this
it captures the spirit
i'm not suggesting lex that everything
the west has done
has been honorable or intelligent
fortunately we live in a democracy we
live in liberal regimes we live under
rule of law
liberal in the classical sense a rule of
law
not liberal in the leftist sense
we live in places like that and we can
criticize ourselves and we can criticize
the mistakes that we made or the policy
choices or the inactions that were taken
and there are a whole lot of things to
answer for
and and and you can
now discuss the ones that are your
favorites
the dishonor or the mistakes
and and i could discuss mine and we
could spend the whole rest of our
meeting today
discussing the west's mistakes in
private and we won't end up in prison
for it
yeah alex and so that's i'm thankful for
that yes and i'm thankful that people
may disagree and that people make the
argument that nato expansion is to blame
but but you see i'm countering two
arguments here
i'm countering one argument
which is very deeply popular pervasive
about how russia has this cultural
tendency to aggression
and it can't help but invade its
neighbors and it does it again and again
and it's eternal russian imperialism
and you have to watch out for it this
very popular argument in the baltic
states it's really popular in warsaw
it's really popular with the liberal
interventionists and it's it's very very
popular with those who are part of the
iraq war squad that got us into that
mess
so i'm against that and the reason i'm
against it is because it's not true it's
empirically false there is no cultural
trait
inherent tendency for russia to be
aggressive it's a strategic choice that
they make every time is the choice made
it's not some kind of momentum every
time it's a choice that we should judge
for the choice that it is for the
decision and therefore they could make
different choices they could say we
don't have to stand up to the west
we don't have the capabilities to do
that we can still be a great country we
can still be a civilization unto itself
we can still be russia
we can still worship in orthodox
cathedrals or
we can still be ourselves
but we don't have to pursue this
chamerical pursuit this elusive quest to
stand up to the west and be in the first
ranks of powers so i'm countering that
argument i'm saying it's a it's
perpetual geopolitics it's a
geopolitical choice rising out of this
dilemma of the mismatch between
aspirations and capabilities it's not
eternal russian imperialism and i'm also
countering the other argument here lex
which is to say that it's the west's
fault
it's western imperialism a very popular
on the left very popular with realist
scholars
very popular with some of the people
recently on your podcast
and so it's neither eternal russian
imperialism nor is it western
imperialism right the mere fact that the
west is stronger than russia is not a
crime on the part of the west
it's not a crime
that countries voluntarily want to join
the west that beg to get in either the
eu
or nato
or other bilateral alliances or other
trade agreements those are voluntarily
entered into
and and that's not criminal if the west
sphere of influence which is open an
open sphere of influence
which as i say people voluntarily join
if that expands that's not a crime nor
is that a threat to russia ipso facto
right nato is a defensive alliance and
the countries are largely pacifists who
are members of nato
and nato doesn't attack it defends
members if they are attacked
and so the idea that ukraine which had
the legal right might want to join nato
in the eu
which was not going to happen in our
lifetimes and was not a direct threat to
the putin regime since it was
since
the
western countries that make up the eu
and
nato uh
decided that ukraine was not ready for
membership there was no consensus it was
not gonna happen but it's ukraine's free
choice to is express that desire
and if your government is elected by
your people freely elected
meaning you can unelect that government
in the next election
and that government makes foreign policy
choices on the basis of its perceived
interests
that's not a crime lex that's not a
provocation
that's not something that compels the
leader of another country to invade you
right that is legal under international
law and it's also a realist fact of life
the realists like to tell you you know
that
russia here was was uh disrespected
russia's interests were not taken into
account etc etc but the real world works
in such a way that treaties matter
that international law matters that's
why people like me were not in favor of
the us 2003 invasion of iraq lex because
it wasn't legal in addition to the fact
that we thought it might backfire
but you know lex
like i said there are a lot of things
about the west that we ought to
criticize as citizens and we do
criticize
but but we have to be clear about where
responsibility lies
in in these events that we're talking
about today
you